la police est toujours à la recherche de
redoine faïd l'ancien braqueur
originaire de creil a disparu il ya un
mois alors que les forces de l'ordre
lancé un vaste coup de filet redoine
faïd est il lié aux hommes qui avait tué
une policière municipale lors d'une
tentative de braquage au printemps
dernier c'est la question que les
enquêteurs voulaient lui poser redoine
faïd venait de sortir un livre braqueur
des cités au grand banditisme
bruno pileje et romain réunion sont
partis sur ses traces mai 1972 un hlm
sur le plateau de creil l'histoire de
redoine faïd commence ici enfants
d'immigrés c'est un bon élève mais
turbulent à l'école ils s'ennuient au
début des années 80 les centres
commerciaux poussent comme des
champignons
redouane a alors que six ans et il est
fait ses premiers pas de voleurs
et puis il y à barbès où son père achète
une boucherie un quartier rêvée pour
l'apprentissage de celui qui n'était
encore qu'un simple délinquant 1984
retour à creil ils enchaînent les vols
parfumerie bar-tabac des coûts qui
rapportent de plus en plus arrivent très
vite les attaques de fourgons blindés de
banque avec séquestration une grande
bijouterie de chantilly ou encore la bnp
de cry en 95 philippe yon ancien
capitaine à la pj de creil se souvient
de fait inédit pour la région en ce qui
concerne les braquages locaux c'était la
première grande équipe qui faisait les
faits les plus graves
redoine faïd ne pense qu'aux braquages
même entre deux coups ils imaginent de
nouvelles attaques toujours mieux
préparé une obsession pour le jeune
homme qui ne se drogue pas ne voit pas
mais avoue une dépendance à l'adrénaline
qui le faisait vivre chez nous on avait
là pour essayer de trouver le plus
rapidement aussi on avait c'était devenu
à l'époque entre guillemets l'ennemi
numéro un redoine faïd est arrêté en 98
et condamné en octobre 2001 à 20 ans de
réclusion par la cour d'assises de
l'oise
c'est la première fois que l'homme doit
s'expliquer sa personnalité apparaît
alors au grand jour vahid est tout à
fait décontracté afin à la maison
d'arrêt était décontractée honnêtement
nous quand on me disait qu'il risqu ait
20 ans et plus il attendait 1
il attendait que ça se passe et c'est un
garçon pragmatique il a examiné les
situations il a vu ce qui pour lui
pouvait le ramener le plus rapidement
possible enfin tout est relatif
le ram est le plus rapidement possible
la liberté finalement sa peine est
ramenée à 12 ans en appel à amiens
et puis il ya ce livre un an après sa
sortie de prison
braqueur des cités au grand banditisme
un livre où il détaille ses braquages sa
vie faite de cavale et d'argent vite
gagner un livre qui n'a pas pour but de
justifier ses actes mais pour montrer un
autre visage celui d'un braqueur sympa
voire d'un ouvrier consciencieux obsédé
par le travail bien fait il le présente
comment dire à son avantage alors que
finalement c'est toute une série de deux
graves infractions et qui vont qui vont
de plus en plus en plus en plus graves
depuis plus de plus en plus dangereux il
ya la réalité des faits il ya des hold
up il ya quand même un trouble à l'ordre
social et qui n'est pas négligeable
et puis vous avez en face quelqu'un qui
est sympathique qui d'ailleurs fait tout
pour drainer la sympathie sympathique et
médiatique
aujourd'hui l'actualité le rattrape
disparu depuis un mois il est soupçonné
d'avoir des liens avec l'équipe de
braqueur recherché dans l'enquêté sur la
fusillade de villiers sur marne en mai
2010 ou est-ce qu'il est qu'est ce qu'il
a fait est il responsable ou pas de ceux
de ce crime - est-ce que la seule chose
que je peux dire c'est qu'il m'a
téléphoné pour me dire qu'il y était
strictement pour rien que bon il n'avait
pas du tout envie de se présenter parce
qu'il savait que a priori il serait
considéré comme coupable et qui
voulaient en terminer il voulait que la
lumière soit faite et il me répétait de
deux ou trois fois
je vous assure je suis strictement pour
rien voilà c'est le seul contact que
j'ai eu avec lui
redoine faïd s'est fait un nom dans le
milieu du grand banditisme
son histoire est celle d'un autodidacte
du braquage
mais comme il le dit j'ai fait le
mauvais choix et les mauvais choix
cela se paye
[Musique]